pensez à un arbre
n'importe lequel
c'est bon vous l'avez
si je vous demandais désormais de le
dessiner la plupart d'entre vous
dessinerez probablement un tronc des
branches un feuillage
ce serait oublier la moitié immergée de
l'iceberg ou plutôt de l'arbre les
racines
les racines sont des ramifications
étendues profondes puissantes elles sont
ce qui donne sa vitalité à l'arbre
pour moi les livres sont aux humains ce
que les racines sont aux arbres
comment les livres nous aident à mieux
vivre
c'est le sujet que j'ai choisi pour mon
intervention
j'aurais pu laisser de côté le mot mieux
comment les livres nous aident à vivre
à m'entendre parler ainsi on pourrait me
prendre pour un rat de bibliothèque loin
sans faux
à 25 ans j'occupe mes journées à bien
d'autres choses
j'ai confondé un média le crayon qui
s'efforce de réunir en créant des
rencontres inédites entre différents
univers différents horizons
nous travaillons également auprès
d'entreprises en tant qu'agent de
créative sur les réseaux sociaux on a
appelé ça le pinceau nous travaillons
pour des entrepreneurs sur le
développement de leur marque personnelle
on a appelé ça le surligneur vous voyez
le thème
enfin depuis janvier je crée du contenu
sur les réseaux sociaux Instagram Tik
Tok YouTube sur l'écologie un peu la
littérature surtout
la portée de mes vidéos auprès de plus
d'une centaine de milliers de personnes
montre à quel point l'envie de lire et
prégnante
mais elle ne s'adresse pas à une
catégorie particulière de boulimique de
lecture qui dévorent sur un livre par an
non cette passion est certes honorable
mais elle est une minorité de niche
mon objectif à moi et de m'adresser à
ceux qui ne sont pas des fanatiques de
lecture qui ne font pas partie de ces
acharnés
alors étant donné qu'il est nécessaire à
l'orateur qui veut convaincre son
auditoire de la légitimité de sa cause
de se montrer à nu je me mets à nu
devant vous ici
figurativement parlant ou désespoir des
premiers rangs
moi non plus je ne suis pas un lecteur
acharné
enfin certes j'ai dévoré des romans
jeunesse Harry Potter et Ragon CHERUB
mais peu à peu à l'âge adolescent les
livres qui jadis ne quittaient pas mes
mains je les ai délaissés à mon chevet
arrivé à 18 ans je ne lisais plus que
peu voire plus
si aujourd'hui cette habitude m'a
reprises
je dois confesser une faiblesse
une faiblesse qui restreint encore le
temps que je dédie à la lecture une
faiblesse qui nous est sans doute
commune je passe trop de temps sur mon
téléphone portable
je scrol indéfiniment sur Instagram Tik
Tok YouTube en parvenant même à me
persuader que c'est utile certes c'est
pour mon métier
formidable si on arrive à se trouver
comme excuse quand il s'agit de
transiger avec sa conscience n'est-ce
pas
ne vous méprenez pas les réseaux sociaux
je les adore enfin je les prends pour
ceux qui le sont ils ont leur travers
mais j'aime la liberté qu'ils permettent
la créativité qu'il favorise la
révolution qu'ils sous tendent
souvent on oppose réseaux sociaux et
livres modernité et traditions vacuité
et profondeur
je m'attache quant à moi à montrer
qu'ils ne sont pas nécessairement
antinomiques créer des ponts et la
mission que c'est fixé le crayon je la
prolonge dans ma création de contenu
les réseaux sociaux sont des
amplificateurs quoi qu'ils amplifient
ils le font puissamment le tout et de
leur donner un bon matériau à amplifier
pour moi ce sont les livres
les livres nous aident à mieux vivre
pour plein de raisons et de plein de
manières j'aimerais en avoir des trois
avec vous aujourd'hui
d'abord le voyage
Balzac écrivait j'ai accompli de
délicieux voyage embarqué sur un mot
certes moi aussi c'est vrai quand je lis
à minime Maalouf j'accompagne à Léon
l'Africain dans son périple autour de la
Méditerranée quand je lis c'était 25
c'est Marie-Antoinette qui renaît à mes
côtés je voyage dans le passé quand je
lis à 12h je voyage dans un monde
alternatif pas si meilleur que ça
quand je lis primo Levy enfin je sens ce
qu'il a vécu à Auschwitz
certains voyages vont l'enfer pour
destination
mais me direz-vous ne peut-on pas
voyager tout aussi bien soi-même
physiquement en présentiel
je dirais pas aussi vite ni aussi loin
probablement pas aussi bon marché et
certainement pas dans le passé
mais elle me direz-vous ne peut-on pas
voyager tout aussi bien en regardant une
série un film une adaptation
cinématographique
certes mais il est une chose que les
films ou les séries ne permettent pas
c'est l'imagination
quand je vois un champ de bataille donc
Game of Thrones une histoire d'amour
dans la Casa de papel ou une dystopie
dans Black Mirror on me les montre
tandis que quand je lis à propos d'un
champ de bataille dans la Chartreuse de
Parme d'une histoire d'amour dans un
incarning ou d'une dystopie de 1984 je
l'imagine
regardez est un processus passif
lire un processus actif on se forge de
sa propre image
qui s'il n'a jamais connu ce sentiment
de découvrir autre un personnage dans
une adaptation cinématographique que
telle qu'il l'avait imaginé dans le
livre dont il est issu
pour moi l'exemple le plus frappant est
Harry Potter
les personnages de Maugrey ou de dolorer
son rage ont marqué mon enfance
au moment de visionner pour la première
fois le film j'avais déjà une image de
ces personnages
certes un peu comme une sauvegarde
d'ordinateur
l'acteur qui incarnait mon Grey a écrasé
quelque peu celui que j'avais imaginé
moi-même
pourtant celui de dollar est Sombrage
mais rester plus de 15 ans après avoir
découvert ce livre c'est dire tout le
pouvoir de l'imagination
alors on tape parfois sur ces longues
phrases ah non plus finir à la Marcelle
Proust c'est description romanesque qui
je dois le confesser moi aussi me barbe
parfois mais elles ont le mérite
d'activer l'imagination d'activer le
cerveau
toute cette activation ça fatigue un peu
non
ça tombe bien
une activité et une seule à ma
connaissance qui permet à la fois de
s'activer et de se reposer
vous l'aurez deviné c'est lire
combien de fois cette année me suis-je
endormi un livre à la main c'est vrai
lire vous propulser dans les bras de
Morphée aussi sûrement que la NASA une
roquette dans l'espace comprenez ça ne
marche pas à tous les coups mais presque
et quand ça échoue c'est moins
désastreux
si lire à ce pouvoir en sommeil en si
profond
c'est parce qu'il produit un apaisement
généralisé du corps en activant le
système parasympathique celui qui détend
l'excitation
je vous promets si vous avez de temps en
temps des difficultés à vous endormir
lisez ça vous calmera
c'est drôle parce qu'en venant sur scène
avec un tel sujet on aurait pu
s'attendre à ce qu'un fanatique de
livres vous parle du bruissement des
pages de leur odeur de leur toucher du
rapport presque physique et charnel au
livre moi je suis là à vous dire lisez
vous endormez plus vite
je ne ferai pas non plus l'offense de
vous encourager à lire pour améliorer
votre vocabulaire ou perfectionner votre
syntaxe non ce serait prendre le risque
de vexer quelques personnes qui ne
manqueraient pas de me demander des
explications à la sortie je m'en
garderai
non
la raison principale pour laquelle
j'ai envie de vous encourager à lire et
la raison pour laquelle je crée mon
contenu la plus fondamentale donc
lire
aide à trouver des réponses aux
questions qu'on se pose dans la vie
j'ai du mal à communiquer dans mon
couple
à comprendre ma moitié à prendre des
décisions sur notre avenir
Mylène kunderra dans la soutenir le
légèreté de l'être m'aidera à réaliser
qu'il est naturel que des
incompréhensions naissent entre époux
car on a forcément des conceptions
différentes d'un même objet
il m'aidera également à réaliser qu'il
est normal de ne pas savoir ce qu'il
faut vouloir car l'être humain n'a
qu'une seule vie et qu'il ne peut ni la
comparer à des vies antérieures ni la
modifier dans des vis ultérieurs
je crains la mort
j'ai peur de quitter ce monde avant
d'avoir accompli tout ce que je pense et
devant accomplir
c'est nec dans ses lettres à son
disciple Lucilius ou Marc Aurèle dans
ses pensées
m'aideront à réaliser que la mort n'est
qu'une étape de la vie celle qui lui
donne son sens et que dissous dans
l'infini de l'univers notre passage sur
terre est insignifiant
je suis en colère contre mes amis
je suis vexé car certaines de leurs
actions se heurtent à mon système de
valeurs mais je ne sais comment les
traiter comment réagir
c'était une bec dans des sourires et des
hommes ou le personnage d'Alceste dans
le Misanthrope de Molière m'aideront à
trancher à savoir si l'amitié doit
pardonner par ce qu'elle est grande ou
rompre par ce qu'elle ne doit plus durer
l'argent l'argent
mine mes relations il s'insinue dans ma
famille la mesquinerie si un filtre
dans la semoir m'aideront à me recentrer
sur ce qui compte vraiment
les livres aident à trouver des réponses
aux questions qu'on se pose dans la vie
c'est tout ce qui fait la valeur des
classiques cette intemporalité
loin d'être un objet d'intellectuel le
livre est un objet essentiel
mais alors si libre et si bon si
précieux si utile pourquoi dit-on si peu
c'est qu'il y a un obstacle
cet obstacle il ne s'agit pas de
franchir une haie de 3 mètres de haut ou
de traverser une rivière infestée de
crocodile non non si encore c'était cela
je vous dirai je comprends d'un sourire
Peugeot une main sur l'épaule c'est
difficile mais non
l'obstacle dont je parle il est rikiki
tout petit n'importe qui peut le
surmonter il se résume à cela
ouvrir le livre
ne le sous-estimons pas c'est un
obstacle psychologique mais un obstacle
le bien réel
mais qui parmi nous ne s'en sont pas
capables
alors
j'ai une faveur à vous demander
pas pour moi pour vous
faites-vous cette promesse
que ce soit lorsque vous serez rentré
chez vous et que vous irez vous coucher
avant de vous endormir saisissez-vous
d'un livre n'importe lequel du théâtre
de la poésie un essai un roman en
classique contemporain peu importe pour
vous qu'il vous intrigue qu'il vous
titille prenez un livre ouvrez-le et
lisez un mot
le premier de la première page
c'est tout
c'est ce dont il suffit
lisez un mot et le reste s'en suivra
alors vous lirez
alors vous vivrez mieux
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]